[Música]
el presidente electo de chile gabriel
boric se reunió con el presidente
saliente sebastián piñera en el palacio
de la moneda para acordar los detalles
del traspaso de poder al encuentro
asistieron el actual gabinete de
ministros y también asesores de boris a
quienes muchos califican como un respiro
para la izquierda latinoamericana en
minutos vamos a analizar el tema
el primer ministro del reino unido-
boris johnson fue fotografiado junto a
su esposa y 17 personas más en un
encuentro sin respetar medidas de
bioseguridad cuando aumentan los casos
de kobe 19 debido a la variante o micro
en el reino unido- y también se le ha
sugerido a los ciudadanos restringir los
encuentros familiares tanto los bares
las escuelas como los restaurantes
también permanecen cerrados
la oms se hizo un llamado a restringir
precisamente las celebraciones de
navidad y de año nuevo ante el aumento
de casos de kobe 19 debido a la variante
omicron el director del organismo
pedrosa da nombre jesús pidió a los
gobiernos tomar medidas para mitigar el
nuevo repunte así las medidas no sean
populares
muy buenas tardes bienvenidos a las
noticias de france 24 soy santiago lópez
gonzález estamos en vivo desde nuestros
estudios en bogotá en colombia vamos a
comenzar en chile en donde el presidente
electo gabriel boric fue recibido en el
palacio de la moneda por el presidente
saliente sebastián piñera para acordar
los detalles del traspaso de poderes a
este encuentro que incluyó también un
almuerzo a puerta cerrada asistieron los
ministros del actual gabinete y los
asesores más cercanos al presidente
electo en una primera reacción a la
victoria de boliche los mercados se
desplomaron en la apertura de la jornada
el peso chileno cayó 302 ante el dólar
estadounidense y la bolsa de comercio de
santiago se desplomó 6,8 por ciento
bobridge de solamente 35 años representa
un nuevo respiro para la izquierda
latinoamericana pero también encarna
valores e ideas como la propuesta de
establecer en chile un sistema del
bienestar similar al que hay en los
países europeos esto dijo el presidente
electo por los chilenos a su salida de
este encuentro en el palacio de la
moneda
tranquilo porque vamos a tener un
traspaso de mando ordenado un traspaso
de mando institucional en donde
el aparato del estado se pone a
disposición de que la democracia
funcione y eso es una buena noticia para
chile porque es algo que quizás uno no
sabe apreciar hasta que se pierde y en
chile tenemos que valorarlo y
profundizar lo vamos a conversar sobre
este tema para analizarlo hemos invitado
a gilberto aranda bustamante él es
académico del instituto de estudios
internacionales de la universidad de
chile se conecta hasta ahora desde la
ciudad de santiago buenas tardes señor
aranda y le pregunto esta lección de
boris representa como lo dicen muchos
analistas un respiro un nuevo aire
digámoslo así para la izquierda
latinoamericana entendiendo que la
izquierda de boris es muy distinta a la
izquierda de maduro en venezuela o díaz
canel en cuba' cuál es su opinión
muy buenas tardes a los tel y las
televidentes desde luego decir que se
trata de una bocanada de aire fresco
porque estamos en presencia de un
recambio generacional es decir es una
nueva generación
muy cercana a millennials que llega al
palacio de la moneda pero al mismo
tiempo insistirles que se trata de una
izquierda variopinta el componente
central de esta izquierda es una
izquierda posmoderna con énfasis de lo
identitario en incluir a diversos
colectivos postergados y comunidades que
han sido discriminada históricamente y
que está en el centro en el corazón de
su programa junto con lo que se ha dicho
el estado de bienestar
señor aranda en su primer discurso
gabriel boric se mostró como un hombre
de consenso de unión y como el
gobernante de todos los chilenos un
mensaje que puede ser muy poderoso para
los chilenos en este momento porque es
un país que está dividido que está muy
polarizado que tanta capacidad tendrá
boris para congregar para unir a los
chilenos después de los hechos que han
vivido en este gobierno de sebastián
piñera
bueno y fundamentalmente a partir de lo
que fue el estallido social de 18
octubre 2019 con réplicas en varios
países incluso donde me está hablando en
colombia también sin lugar a dudas en un
gran desafío el hablado de alguna manera
de acuerdos y reencuentros estamos
hablando por cierto de un contexto de
segunda vuelta donde se dirigió también
a sectores de más más de mayor
moderación de alguna manera la
centroizquierda también abrió este
candidato que es de izquierdas y por
supuesto con movilización de sectores y
que la herencia del pinochetismo
representado en el señor cast en el
candidato cas le hacía el sentido de
anticuerpos así que podríamos decir que
son muchos los desafíos señor aranda
muchos analistas algunos medios chilenos
usted también mencionaba que se trata de
una nueva generación leyendo los
titulares de la prensa chilena de
algunos que dicen que chile
que en este país terminó la transición y
que ahora está comenzando un nuevo
capítulo en la historia política del
país usted lo ve así
pues la verdad es que muchas veces se ha
hablado el fin de la transición el 94 o
el 2006 y nuevamente en este caso ahora
lo que sí tenemos una nueva generación
que entra al palacio de la moneda en
chile y tenemos un nuevo sistema de
partido un nuevo orden político que va a
tener otras coordenadas y probablemente
otras prioridades en el sentido bastante
nuevo y hay que decirlo en una bocanada
de aire para la izquierda porque en
latinoamericana porque ciertamente al
menos él el presidente electo moriche ha
insistido en un discurso aunque
autoritario que apunte a gobiernos como
los de venezuela y nicaragua
usted menciona venezuela y nicaragua el
mismo el presidente electo gabriel bordi
ha criticado a estos gobiernos en estos
países latinoamericanos que
relacionamiento podrá tener a nivel
internacional este nuevo gobierno en
chile dado el mapa político que vemos en
la región hay gobiernos de la derecha de
un extremo como brasil otro gobierno de
derecha como colombia pero vemos otros
gobiernos de izquierdas que pueden ser
grandes aliados de boris en los en este
gobierno que va a empezar como lo ve
usted
bueno básicamente que se adquiere una
mayor sintonía y convergencia política
en los énfasis sociales y económicos con
gobiernos vecinos a chile' me estoy
refiriendo a perú bolivia y argentina
pero básicamente en esta hora de esta
luna de miel entre la elección y la
entrada como presidente ya
institucionalmente a la moneda diría que
se van a multiplicar los que esto hacía
argentina esa es la sensación que
probablemente con argentina se va a
intentar fortalecer la relación además
es el vecino inmediato allí en chile-
gilberto aranda desde la ciudad de
santiago muchas gracias por este
análisis para la audiencia de france 24
cambiamos de tema un nuevo escándalo ha
afectado al primer ministro británico
boris johnson a quien en una fotografía
publicada por el diario the garden se lo
ve junto a su esposa y a 17 personas más
en el jardín de downing street la
residencia oficial según el portavoz de
johnson se trataba de una reunión de
trabajo pero los asistentes no
respetaron el distanciamiento social y
estaban tomando vino y comiendo queso la
imagen toma mucha relevancia en estos
momentos en el reino unido en el que
están cerrados y los bares los
restaurantes y se les sugirió a los
británicos evitar las reuniones
familiares y las aglomeraciones entre
otras restricciones ante el rápido
avance de contagio que deja la variante
omicron en ese país el primer ministro
se refirió a este tema escuchemos
esas eran personas en el trabajo eran
reuniones de personas hablando de
trabajo este es el lugar donde vivo y es
el lugar donde trabajo esas eran
reuniones de personas trabajando
hablando de trabajo y realmente creo que
es vital que nos concentremos si podemos
en los mensajes que estamos tratando de
transmitir hoy nos enfrentamos a un
aumento grave en om y chrome estamos
viendo que los casos aumentan en londres
en particular los casos de
hospitalizaciones y la respuesta es ser
cauteloso pero también vacunarse
masnoticias el director general de la
omct edrosa among abre jesus recomendó
cancelar los eventos planeados para las
fiestas de navidad y de año nuevo ante
el aumento de casos de contagio de kobe
19 a nivel mundial en una conferencia de
prensa en la ciudad de ginebra en suiza
el director general aseguró que la
variante omicron puede ser contraída por
personas que ya cuentan con un esquema
completo de vacunación o que ya se
infectaron de kobe 19 en el pasado
pedrós hizo un llamado a tomar
conciencia frente a esta situación ante
las festividades de fin de año y también
instó a los gobiernos a tomar decisiones
así las decisiones no sean populares
todos estamos cansados de estas
pandemias todos queremos pasar tiempo
con amigos y familiares todos queremos
volver a la normalidad la forma más
rápida de hacer esto es que todos
nosotros los líderes y las personas
probemos las decisiones difíciles que
deben tomarse para protegernos a
nosotros mismos ya los demás en algunos
casos eso significará cancelar o
reemplazar eventos al igual que hemos
tenido que cancelar la recepción que
planeamos tener hoy pero un evento
cancelado es mejor que una vida
cancelada es mejor cancelar ahora y
celebrar más tarde que celebrar ahora y
llorar más tarde ninguno de nosotros
quiere volver a estar aquí dentro de 12
meses
hay que seguir cuidándose es todo por el
momento en las noticias de france 24
sigan con nuestra programación muy
buenas tardes para todos
[Música]